it was a beautiful summer morning I open
my eyes in the warm sunshine and then I
walk to the restroom wash my face and
look at myself in the mirror and smiled
then I realized something was wrong
the per centimeter tried to smile but
the smile was broken and cold this was a
day when I realized half of my face was
paralyzed I lost the ability to move the
right side on my face I could not blink
or close my right eye so I always need
to wear an eyepatch
during the day and put tape on my eye to
fall asleep at night and there was
always spit dripping from my mouth I
visited a major hospital in South Korea
but there was a new doctor who could
clearly tell me why I had this illness
and how to treat it
I was a 19 year old girl who loved to
put on makeup and dress up but the only
thing I could do was lie in the hospital
bed and cry I blamed my doctors and this
illness and I blamed even myself I was
really devastated and one day my mom
asked me do you remember your stuffed
animal you know that fluffy seal
whenever you hugged it it made you feel
better yeah how can I forget my stuff
seal my parents gave it to me as a
present when I was three and I really
loved it it was the most unique stuffed
animal in Korea at the time and I still
member that it was a kind of bit
difficult to unwrap gift box by myself
because the fluffy seal was as tall as I
was at 3 all and I also still remember
that how excited I was when I finally
took out my seal from the box then
suddenly at the moment the
thought came to my mind maybe this
illness is also one of the gifts I
received from my life or gift kind of
ugly and crappy outside but may have
something beautiful inside and it is a
painful and difficult to unwrap this
gift because I'm getting a really giant
one so from this moment I try to stop
complaining complaining about this
illness and try to feel good about it
and as you can imagine it was not easy I
couldn't stop thinking that okay so
let's say this is the gift but why am I
the only one getting these crappy gifts
when my friends are enjoying their
summer vacation and I also ask myself
questions like what if there is nothing
inside of this gift box what is the
point over my suffering and those
carrots part was what if my face stays
paralyzed forever I struggled a lot many
attempts were in vain but the one thing
I didn't give up was thinking that there
might be my stuffed seal inside of this
painful gift so I began thinking you
know positive sides of this illness and
to my surprise there were a list of you
so my illness gave me not only a chance
to rest but also an excuse to avoid my
mom's nagging my mom couldn't say a word
whenever I over stop and read a comic
books in my bed also I began burying
things I took for granted my smile my
health my friends and family who cared
so much about me after weeks of this
practice my emotion toward this illness
evolved into a gratefulness it may sound
really weird but I felt grateful for
having this facial paralysis as I did
for my stuff sill
in the meantime my face which had not
been healed by Western medicine or a
Chinese acupuncture weekend showing
improvements and in the end the right
side of my face came back to its
original condition without any side
effects I am looking at my gift box my
gift box named facial paralysis and when
I opened it up one of the gifts inside
was this newland and when I looked
through the lens I could have seen not
just blessings as a blessings but also
burdens as plastics there are people
being grateful for difficulties or
hardships long after that event has
passed what I believe they're singing
burdens as a blessings in the midst of
those burdens helped me a lot to recover
but you know being grateful for burdens
that's a lot of work it took me weeks in
a month to feel genuinely grateful for
this burden so why should we bother it
turns out there has been a lot of
research showing the positive effects of
gratitude and being on X business
consultant here like like any other
great consultant I categorize those
impacts into three buckets my variable
number body brain in our emotions
gratitude is good for our body
many studies done by gratitude expert
dr. Emmons at UC Davis show that in list
to 12 percent lower blood pressure 10
percent less stressed about illnesses
and more embarrassing all of which are
critical for curing illnesses also it
helps our brain to when you feel
grateful your brain produces a surge of
feel good and happy brain chemicals like
dopamine or serotonin also it is good
for our emotion grateful people feel 25%
happier and less depressed and more
importantly it makes us emotionally
resilient to hard times giving us the
power to heal and bringing us hope so
now that we know that gratitude is
scientifically proven to be good for us
so let's talk about how
it is a relatively easy to say thank you
for blessing such as free coffee shop
nice weather at the GSB and classmates
awesome talk but it is getting things
are getting tougher when something bad
happens like catching a cold or fighting
with our partner getting or parking
tickets
how can you feel grateful for getting a
parking ticket so here are some steps I
saw just you as a someone still
struggling to hone the art of gratitude
so step one is facing it
you got the damn parking ticket do not
ignore your burden is not of our
self-deception and in step two is
breathing
instead of saying [ __ ] or [ __ ] I love to
say those words I try to stop and
breathe to relieve your anger and next
the most important step is you need to
make a choice what choice you need to
choose to be grateful for this parking
ticket I know it's not easy but in fact
gratitude is all about choice and fourth
the most painful part is reflecting
think about how this parking ticket does
something good for you imagine yourself
holding the gift box wrapped with ugly
parking tickets like this what's inside
of the box so for me actually I don't
have a car so I would feel really
grateful for the fact that I had a car
so I could get the parking ticket
also we could be thankful for the
warning sign that tells us to not park
here again prevents us from getting more
expensive parking tickets in the future
so we just made a very tough choice to
be grateful for this parking ticket but
this choice gets even more challenging
when when life throws really be gift
boxes at you like illness loss the end
of a relationship and honestly I am
still struggling here too in my
experience there is an OK fix it takes n
Lewis training to see burdens as
blessings but I hope my talk today helps
you see your own burdens as gifts so
that you can take out your own stuffed
animal with joy from those gift boxes
thank you